los líderes europeos se reúnen por
segundo día consecutivo aquí en Bruselas
después de que ayer se centraran en la
ayuda a Ucrania la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursola founderlayer
anunció una iniciativa junto al Primer
Ministro polaco mateus Mora viequiel que
se organizará una conferencia en los
próximos días para tratar de localizar
los más de 16.000 niños secuestrados y
llevados a la fuerza a Rusia hoy por su
parte los líderes europeos se van a
centrar sobre la situación económica
especialmente las turbulencias
económicas que se han podido vivir en
los últimos días tras la caída del banco
de silicon Valley de
los 27 se han dado cuenta en estos
últimos días en que aún no se ha acabado
la reforma bancaria que empezó con la
gran crisis de 2008 los líderes europeos
se van a encontrar al respecto con la
presidenta del Banco Central europeo
Christine lagart en que van a abordar
las medidas leurobanco especialmente el
aumento de los tipos de interés en medio
punto anunciados la semana pasada la
lucha contra la lación pero también con
el claro mensaje de que la entidad está
dispuesta a inyectar liquidez si hace
falta para calmar a los mercados
Bruselas también está dispuesta en los
próximos días a lanzar una nueva
propuesta para atajar cualquier tipo de
crisis financiera en cualquier caso
desde la Unión Europea se quiere enviar
un mensaje de tranquilidad y que dejar
Claro que la situación actual nada tiene
que ver con la gran crisis de 2008